people hear the words pathology they
usually usually think about the law and
order or the pathologies investigating
some kind of uh you know
death or murder etc and but um and i was
also thinking that but four years ago
when we started uh doing projects in
digital pathology i actually came to
understand that
pathology is actually the science of
uh i think which actually cherishes life
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders and let's
dive deep into one of the most important
verticals in the high-tech sector
pathology meet ken segev the co-founder
and co-ceo of deep pathology ai she is
also the founder of sagivtech and
surgeon ai ken is a phd in applied math
from the tel aviv university
specializing in computer vision she
loves math and the mix of algorithms and
health care she lives in gosh with her
husband twin girls and two dogs
penn stage welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for joining me
thank you for having me mikhail a
pleasure to be here and uh super excited
to participate in young ram show
thank you i'm i'm super excited and
honored to have you here because the
work that you're doing you know it's
pretty rare that i get to sit with
somebody that that really you know the
work that they're doing on a very deep
level is changing paradigms and it's
changing ways in which we interact with
the human body and thinking through
humanity and and how do we actually
tackle some of the most challenging
problems and so in these 20 minutes i
want to talk both about your your
experience with with the pathology and
sagivtech and surgeon ai obviously
you're deep into the artificial
intelligence space when it comes also to
the human body and research and and i
think it's going to be fascinating to
understand first you know on the high
level context what is pathology and then
how are you translating ai technology to
go and and make make a strong impact
over there so take me a little bit
through your journey up until deep
pathology and then we'll get into those
fun subjects okay great fantastic so
um so i'm uh i was born and raised in
israel and from when i was a kid i
always
loved mathematics so when i graduated
from the army i i was actually
i was adopting before between physics
computer science and medicine and i was
lucky enough to be accepted to all and
then i said okay i'm afraid of blood and
and i i'm going to cry all the time as a
doctor so i cannot harm anyone with
physics so i did my first and second
degrees in physics and then i i was
lucky enough to do my phd and apply the
mathematics and in between work in
israel in the netherlands uh in
algorithms the development in the
medical domain but not only and then
12 and a half years ago
and my husband and i so my husband
nissan is from the uh more business
oriented field it was uh
over seeing the business units from um
business perspectives sales money etc so
when we decided to join forces after
raising twins who are now at 23 so after
you raise swings
you know running companies is just
much much simpler
and this is this is true and uh
and then so we joined forces and started
as a process company
specializing in computer vision and gpu
computing at a time
uh i think that like um six seven years
ago the ar revolution really swept the
industry and we really shifted our gears
towards
ai and computer vision and also
tech was some kind of an incubator to
both the pathology and surgeon ai which
are both uh private companies
uh so and i think the pathology is more
immature so where it's already alive and
kicking and selling and
staying
on its own two feet and i think that if
you like i can also go into pathology
please do
okay fantastic so
uh when people hear the words pathology
they usually usually think about the law
and order or the pathologies
investigating some kind of uh you know
death or murder etc
and i was also thinking that but four
years ago when we started uh doing
projects in the digital pathology i
actually came to understand that
pathology is actually the science of
uh i think which actually cherishes life
because um when people go through
biopsies for example and so there's a
tissue
it's a slice it's colored because uh the
the cells are not incoming in colors and
and then the pathologist the expert
pathologist is actually uh looking at
the biopsy to see whether there is
cancer uh where there is some kind of
infectious disease to give the diagnosis
and also to recommend a treatment and
the role of pathologies is crucial in
the diagnosis and in um
actually
providing the right treatments and this
is in
diagnosis but also in formal research in
developing new drugs to evaluate the
efficiency and the toxicity of new drugs
you also need to evaluate
the biopsies and the biopsies could be
in pre-clinical trials or animals or of
actually you know in large clinical
trials of humans where you want to see
how the drug is actually
working and you need in order to do that
to quantify different kind of cells
tumor cells
immune cells etc and all of this
has been done analogue in an analog way
under a microscope where people were
counting things you know one two three
four five
and
uh the introduction of digital pathology
is actually you know it was a game
changer and and i think the introduction
of
digital information you know it sounds
so trivial trivial for someone from your
generation because everything is digital
but you know i i was there listening to
to to records and you know and then was
there using the
pencils to to to fix my cassettes so for
me digital is far from being obvious
and it's fascinating to see how
digitation is invading so many fields in
medicine
and it actually is an enabling
technology super super important because
you cannot apply ai
on analog information
you need digitation and radiology was
first
then pathology
surgery and i'm just thinking what will
be next i i don't know i mean all the
medical data is being digitized and this
i i think that this is uh like you know
um
a revolution which is as important as
antibiotics as vaccination wow
yeah i i really believe that and i think
it's fascinating to to be a part a small
part of this fantastic revolution
so how is this first of all
what how how is this revolution actually
taking place when is it taking place is
it already finished is it are we where
are we in terms of it both the
digitalization but but then you know
what you're working on is actually the
layer on top of the digitalization right
actually now data-driven insights and
technologies that actually help do
research not just through what we
studied in academia from our personal
experiences but but through software
that can look at millions of data points
so so what's happening so so yeah i i
think there's a lot going on there's
really a lot going on it's unbelievable
it's the ecosystem for radiology for
pathology and now for surgery i think
it's booming and still
there is
um there is a gap between i think the
state-of-the-art technology which is you
know
just
unbelievable and what is happening in
real life and i want you to address
three points here the first thing is the
enabling technology that the bringing
i.t to the medical world is far from
being trivial because it's not uh i mean
i t issues which are so like fundamental
the bread and butter in so many domains
they still need to make their way into
so they did make their way to the
radiology because in radiology with
dicom
things are more strongest
but in pathology uh most technology labs
in the world are still not digital
and there's still it's it involves a
huge amount of money of resources of
change of um the way that things are
being done
and then you know
doctors are really i think suspicious
because they want to know that when they
use a digital system that what you see
on the screen is actually what you see
under the microscope and this is really
fundamental it's it's
way before you apply any ai algorithms
to it
and and i think that um
to make a revolution you really need to
go with the medical doctors so that you
are flowing you are within their
workflow you are not interrupting their
workflow so
the digitization in the western world in
pathology labs is still something which
is uh
needs to be completed when it comes to
surgery so i'm talking about
laparoscopic surgeries where you
actually the the surgery is being done
when the surgeon is looking on the
screen now these videos of the surgery
are just
not existing after the surgery is over
because
nobody is archiving them
and nobody is using them not for ai not
for nothing
and just think about
so so you know in pathology you're
talking about slides there are huge
slides but you're talking about frames
in surgery you're talking about videos
so just think about the amount of
information that you want to archive
it's it's unbelievable so so just
building a reasonable infrastructure
in terms of archiving solutions of in
terms of the
uh smart video summarization techniques
this is like a fundamental uh
infrastructure which is still being
built it's not it's not over yet at all
now once you have a solid enough
infrastructure you can start thinking
about algorithms ai computer vision all
these good stuff and
and while i know so many companies both
in israel and in the us and just in the
in the in the scandinavia in india
which are my competition
but
are part of a very thriving ecosystem
and you know there are such huge tasks
to be solved that no single company
even even a large company no single
company can actually provide solutions
to all the problems that medical
profession has to offer so i strongly
believe in an ecosystem
which that that can communicate that so
that as a physician i will be able to
say okay i need one two three and i can
and all these solutions can interact
with each other so my vision is not only
to have
great solutions of my own company but to
be to to have solutions which are smart
enough to integrate into
an ecosystem and this is i think there's
still a gap here because it doesn't make
sense
that you will have to
really um
right now it's
the solutions are out there some of them
already had fda approvals but it's very
difficult to have them in the usual
routine and usual workflow and i think
this integration is the big big
challenge
and the first thing is i think to to
really see um
these solutions
as part of the routine work of the
physicians so our vision in deep
pathology is to bring ai capabilities to
the hands of the doctors
because the way that we envision that
ai should not be in the sole domain of
computer scientists of engineer or data
scientist but ai tools should be
available
uh as as as as
as a very sophisticated computer
uh or uh
to be to be part of what pathologists or
surgeons of radiologists can actually
work on explore investigate because in
in our vision
that the right way to move forward is to
join forces between the
ai experts and the domain experts being
that topology of radiology or surgery
and all these such um uh and let's say
working together can really bring
meaningful and and and you know and and
the
results that you can actually implement
in practice
and so today what is the balance like
for you between you've been you as a
physician you as an entrepreneur as a
researcher
as a visionary and a pioneer in a field
which what it sounds to me from your
description we're really just beginning
right we're really in the roots of of
where we're going to end up in so so
it's it's a lot of responsibility that
you're also taking on yourself to to to
run through with this domain and
and so how do you balance all these
different characteristics um
so so i think it's an excellent question
i think you know i think that uh moving
towards balance
know
is a life mission
in so many levels personal levels
professional levels i think that here in
order to um
to really
balance out things i really i strongly
believe in communication so
i i i i know
you know fantastic people who come with
superb ideas with super capabilities but
only uh by um
really understanding the needs
and so i think for me uh somewhere when
coming from mathematics and from
algorithms i need to really understand
the problems the language that the the
the the mindset of the medical doctors
otherwise i i i it doesn't make any
sense to make a technology which is not
rooted in a real clinical needs on the
other end i strongly believe that the
clinicians should at least understand a
little bit about the technology so that
they i don't expect them to start
writing in pie torch or knowing
tensorflow or whatever um
but they do need to understand
the principles the limitations
the way to evaluate think and the way to
be critical and this is by the way the
reason why i started my my course ai for
pathologists because i i was thinking
well you need to make some kind of
common grounds where pathologists um
medical doctors can actually talk to the
ai experts to mathematicians and this
collaboration i i you know without
respect to artificial intelligence
i believe that human intelligence
is something that will actually will
make things uh move forward and and part
of being
an intelligent human is to listen
to other humans and and to and to really
understand
um
what they need and what will bring value
because eventually if you don't bring
value to your customers to patients
uh then then you don't do anything
meaningful
now is artificial intelligence already
making it a dramatic impact on pathology
and research today and or or
where are we at i think is the question
because i think that we we both agree
that it's inevitable and it's going to
be very transformative i'm wondering
where where are we at with this timeline
of of this transformation uh so yeah so
i think artificial intelligence actually
uh um started to be meaningful in
pathology i think
from about four to five years ago you
know when when when
uh people started experimenting i think
that nowadays you see already a solid ai
based solution for diagnosis you see uh
how pharma companies are using ai to
develop new drugs and to evaluate the
clinical trials and to really extract to
to to make the most for
extracting valuable
information from from data
i think that yes it does make an impact
i think that um four years ago
uh
we i talked to a lot of pathologists and
four years ago they were really
reluctant and you know very suspicious
and why shall we embrace that it will
replace us
and nowadays i think that they really
see it as a decision support system that
will allow them to um to get rid of the
time consuming tedious
you know unpleasant tasks and really
focus on the higher
uh
level tasks so i think that at some
point maybe you can view
medical
experts as pilots that they have a very
sophisticated machine but they control
it and they make a decision where when
it will be autopilot and when
they are needed in a riskier
in places where you need someone to to
really you know balance out the the the
ai and to bring the human intelligence
thing so so i think yes it already has
some impact it already
and it's not only in the state of early
adapters i think it's
gradually um entering the the mainstream
but don't forget
uh the the
when you look at poor countries when you
look at smaller hospitals
the the
in order to jump
onto the ai train you need to invest a
lot of money and i think that this is
why uh this is something that is being
done
uh is strategically by governments
because to become let's say ai ready
is is something that uh that countries
should to strive for and this is why we
need to build an ecosystem uh which is
not only made of uh small or large
companies but also that the the medical
stakeholders and also the the the
countries which should take care of the
regulation so that
privacy issues are really really uh you
know kept in the strictest way and that
patient's rights are kept but also to
to make an infrastructure because
eventually a.i i believe in in the
medical field will make us
live longer we'll make our life
easier because i think that we will be
able to diagnose diseases much earlier
and
provide
a a medications or treatment which is
personalized so so i really believe that
this is a tremendous revolution
and that that they will help people live
better i really i really believe that
i i love it and i can
no i think the beginning of the
conversation you helped answer my
question of what fat what fascinated you
growing up and i think you just answered
my question of what inspires you today
and thank you for everything
and stay safe and stay healthy
foreign